– Ja, okay, in zwei Stunden.
Ich hole dich ab!
Ich freue mich auch!
Tschüss!
Das kann doch nicht wahr sein!
– Morgen!
– Guten Morgen.
Sehen Sie das?
Ich möchte nicht, dass die Mülltonne
vor meinem Laden steht.
Wie oft soll ich das noch sagen?
– Ich finde ja, Sie sollten sich
einfach mal entspannen und …
- Entspannen?
– Ja. Außerdem wollte ich
gerade zu Ihnen, weil …
– Ich habe jetzt keine Zeit
für Diskussionen.
Ich bekomme Besuch und muss
eine Stadtbesichtigung planen.
– Oh, da kann ich Ihnen vielleicht helfen
und Ihnen ein paar Tipps geben.
Sie sollten auf jeden Fall
das Stadtschloss besuchen.
Die aktuelle Dürer-Ausstellung
ist wirklich sehr schön.
– Danke, aber ich …
– Im kleinen Theater gibt es
außerdem ein neues Programm.
Ich bin wirklich neugierig
auf die Faust-Interpretation.
Sie kennen doch „Faust“ von Goethe, oder?
– Ja natürlich. Aber ich hab …
– Hier, sehen Sie:
Ein Kritiker schreibt in der Zeitung – hier:
„Goethes Faust begeisterte die
Theaterbesucher gleich am ersten Abend.“
Ja. Es gab langen Applaus:
„Die Schauspieler mussten dreimal
wieder auf die Bühne kommen.“
– Ja, sehr schön. Aber …
– Die Gemälde aus dem
Mittelalter im Stadtmuseum
– die sind auch ein echter Geheimtipp.
Sehr schöne Bilder!
Das steht in keinem Stadtführer.
Aber gehen Sie bitte auf keinen Fall
in das Museum für moderne Kunst.
Das lohnt sich gar nicht.